again we will divide
in four groups we will start by making
sweat now you're experts you know how to
make a sweat
okay either with chipola or
with the albion my recommendation would
be
that the people who are using
the radicchio would make the sweat with
allio while for the others i think
chipotle would be better
then the next step will consist in
taking the
piezo
and we will mix it
and we will toast it a tiny bit
after that we will add the broth
so while the sweat is cooking you will
have to prepare
some broth and i will tell you then
all the details of the other details on
the way good
you have cutting boards they are on the
other side
kitchens wash your hands
if you want you can put the radicchio
with gonna be very good so you have to
wash your hose and just
chop it very very thin
so what i want you to do is practice
and then get through it together and
then you make
pieces about the size
is ready i will tell you like each
recipe has a different order in the
ingredients but then at some point you
will add
the rice with the fire a little bit
higher
so otherwise it starts to stick just for
a couple of minutes and then we have the
problem so how much rice
typically you can consider something
like 80 grams
per person i usually do something like
100 pounds
so well you have the rice you have the
scale
i would say each team can cook something
like 400 grams
how much is in each bag um
i told you we were going to add the
broth
but we would use a trick instead of
adding the broth i'm going to take
idado and put it in your
sofrito yeah and then we will add the
water
hot water boiling water so the advantage
is that
well we will have one pot less to clean
per group
so you should do this in your dorm it's
also something to take into
consideration
so we take the data we put it in the
software
and then it's important when you add the
water it has to be boiling water not
cold
okay now what we are doing we are
toasting it
a tiny bit but we don't want it to stick
we just toast it for a minute
and you add the adding yeah
after we add the water we stir but then
we just
leave
so we keep adding hot water and
we stir every i don't know four or five
minutes
and when it's ready how do we know when
it's ready
we eat it we taste a tiny bit
and we decide and we may also have to
add salt most likely you will have to
add a little bit of salt
so you taste it you decide is it hard
is it soft do i need to add a little bit
of salt
so here it's different from when we make
pasta when we make pasta we put
a lot of salt because then we get rid of
the water with the risotto we keep
everything
in the same pot so when you add salt you
really add just a pinch at the time
oh
when the rice is almost ready
it's
oh
okay
how much did you sprinkle
no just like that not too long less than
a minute
for the sausage
i need to make the camera oh my goodness
thank you gotcha wait i'm gonna take six
five four three two
oh yeah
oh